like to thank the organizers for a great
workshop and for having me here I'm
going to be talking about a noisy
estimation of simultaneously structured
models so and this is a joint work with
my students I mean july at university of
washington and or collaborators somnath
a mac and baba Cassie be at Caltech and
the first part of the talk also has
contribution by you and Nina elder from
technion okay so I'm going to be talking
about problems where we would like to
find a model so there is an underlying
model and you obtain so abstractly this
is what's going on there's an underlying
model and you obtain information from
that model the information can be
incomplete it and it can be noisy and
based on that you would like to
reconstruct find or recover the original
model the only hope we would have to do
this if your information is limited or
if you're in a high-dimensional setting
is if you have any prior assumption on
the model if you know something about it
for example you know it's structured in
certain ways okay so we are going to
look at models like this in that kind of
settings that are in a high dimensional
space but have enough structure they
have a low dimensional structure or low
degrees of freedom and we're going to
exploit the fact that they have no
degrees of freedom to be able to
computationally efficiently reconstruct
or recover these models and so what we
mean by no degrees of freedom is the
same theme of the workshop which is they
allow force extent representations it's
very useful to exploit such structure in
many different tasks it's helpful
basically for compression data
acquisition for storage for data mining
and all of that you have probably seen a
lot of example so i won't go into too
many of that details but what is needed
in these all these scenarios are
computationally efficient ways to be
able to reconstruct these the original
model in a limited information setting
where the information is also noisy so
i'm going to in particular look at
convex relaxations or convex regular
risers to capture this prior information
this is a little bit similar to the
spirit of what van cott was talking
about this morning using convex
relaxations
so what do we mean by no dimensional
structures so I think a lot of these are
very familiar for you guys but let's
just go over them to as a review the
most famous most popular one that comes
up in many different fields is sparse
vectors vectors that have a lot of zeros
in them that makes them no dimensional
groups force vectors there are chunks of
non zeros in the vector doe ranked
matrices they have a lot of zero
eigenvalues or singular values and
actually the list goes on and on you can
also talk about low rank tensors rank in
different notions support for a tensor
and so on but also a more interesting
combinations of these things can arise
for example in a certain problems that
are raising graphical models where there
are some hidden variables or also arise
in principal component analysis where
you have corruption by outliers what you
have is you are looking at models that
are summation of different structured
models for example a low rank matrix
plus escorts matrix okay but in this
talk I'm going to look at another way
that combines different structures not
summing them up and looking at a
summation you're not given information
on the summation but we are looking to
find models that are simultaneously
structured in different ways for example
matrices that are both low rank and
spores and where does that come up one
application is in signal processing is
called phase retrieval and here is that
problem so so this is 1 i'll mention
some other applications after but this
one in arises in optics and signaled
optical signal processing and especially
whenever you are having so here we have
a signal X naught it's a vector in RN
let's say and we would like to recover
it from linear measurements so that
means I have AI transpose X X knots
right so AI is a sensing vector however
with 11 problem and that is that you
have an absolute value you lose the sign
of that measurement those are called
faceless measurements so I want to
reconstruct the signal X not given an M
phase those measurements of the signal
how can we do this well so this problem
is no longer linear I cannot write a
linear equality constraint it is non
convex as written because of the
absolute value but is
standard trick to deal with it is using
something called lifting you define a
new matrix capital X that is the outer
product of X nonton itself and this
matrix now is ranked 1 because of the
way it's constructed and so i can write
my problems in terms of finding a matrix
that's positive semi-definite that is
ranked 1 on agrees with my measurements
so now it became a matrix problem
because of the lifting so so far the
only structure I needed this matrix to
have was bps DMV ranked 1 but what if I
also know the signal X not is a sparse
signal it has a lot of zeros in it so
now the matrix X is both ranked 1 and
block sports in fact it's really simple
it has tons of zeros it has only like k
k by k nonzero elements inside a big
matrix that has lots of zeros so looks
simple but it does reduce to two
different structures that we require or
variable to have so that's one
application and this way of lifting this
particular phase retrieval problem was
first mentioned in this paper by Candace
and others but the problem is actually
very old goes back to 60s and even older
in optics so some other applications in
which i have matrices that are low rank
and spars arises in cluster detection
where basically you look for block
diagonal matrix given various
observations and this has been looked at
in this paper also the problem of sparse
pca that several people talked about can
be viewed as related to this because you
are looking for a matrix that has low
rank and its eigenvectors are sparse so
you can again think about it in lifted
terms you're looking for low ranking
sports matrices okay and some other
applications of this idea but in general
what I want to look at is I would like
to do estimation of these structured
models I will set it up but the talk is
going to focus in this case where we
have simultaneous structures in one
model so what's the setup so we have an
unknown structured Model X naught in RN
and is the ambient dimension it can be
very large and I don't have two problems
so these come up in slightly different
literature but the math behind them is
actually pretty close one is compressed
sensing measure the compressed sensing
area so when I say I have compressed
measurements it means that I have AG
let's say a matrix that is M by n where
m is much less than n that multiplies my
vector and gives me measurement vector Y
and for the analysis in this talk this
measurement matrix is going to be random
Gaussian by ID but we can't comment on
that later another setup that's studied
more in statistics it's called the noisy
it's simpler you don't have do identity
the measurement map the measurement map
is identity simple have simply have the
structure signal corrupted by noise and
you were just want to get rid of noise
and here for varsity up again for this
talk we are going to assume the noise is
Gaussian led the vector Z so these two
scenarios and in these two scenarios we
are given the G given the why we know
the structure type and we want to find
it's not so the question is how do we do
it what kind of computationally
efficient way can we do it and there are
a couple of other interesting questions
one can ask in these scenarios one is
that how many measurements M suffice so
what is m m is right here is the number
of rows and that G matrix the number of
Gaussian measurements you are given and
how many measurements do we need for us
to be able to in a competition efficient
efficient we reconstruct X naught and so
that notion is close to what's known as
sample complexity in machine learning
how many am do you need another question
that we asked as more of a statistical
flavor is how does the mean square error
behave with noise level so if I
construct an estimator in this problem
that gives me an X hat and I look at the
expected value of x dot minus X hat
square how does that scale as my signal
to noise ratio changes for the front
estimator so we are interested in those
two questions so now let's actually make
it concrete let's review some very very
well known problems that are related to
this setup and especially these problems
are related to the compressed
measurement setup okay so the simplest
is that I have a vector X naught that is
case force k nonzero entries in a vector
of size n and well so I'm given these
rezian observations I know it's not
satisfy these equations and I want to
find the sports s vector so this l0 norm
notation means the number of nonzero
entries or the cardinality so I want to
find the sparsa spector subject to
measurements one question that we can
ask is that well if i have enough
measurements if m equals n eventually
obviously there's a unique solution so
we don't even need to worry about it but
how big should mb for this solution to
be unique and therefore x not to be for
any method to have any hope of
reconstructing exxon so the answer there
is actually order k order k observations
or order k measurements are enough and
the little bit more precise order key
observations are enough to reconstruct x
not with high probability what do i mean
by that probability distribution is over
the random gaussian measurement g and by
high probability we mean probability
that is basically approaching one
exponentially in the number of
measurements em see here is a constant
so approaches one very fast ok but this
problem is not convict because of that
cardinality objective so it cannot be
solved efficiently and what do people do
in practice is that let's use a convex
relaxation and i would guess that most
of you have seen this so this is just a
review people tend to use the l1 norm
some of the absolute values of the
vector as a relaxation subject to the
same constraints now the thing I'm
interested in is what about the M what
about sample complex see what sample
complexity with this problem have to
reconstruct X not correctly and in this
case the answer is the M that you need
for the solution of this optimization
problem to be equal to X naught is order
ke logon ke logon / k so that's old
result why now it's actually goes back
to maybe even older hints of it but it
actually appeared in the work of Candace
Romberg toe in 2004 Donahoe and others
and this gave rise to this whole area of
compressed sensing it's a very important
result and its really striking because
if you compare these two programs with
each other this one is not convex
you can solve it and it required k
measurements this one is convex and it
only requires k Dorgan so you're only
using an audience actor so that's that's
actually why this whole area really
works well this was amazing about the
result second example is low rank matrix
reconstruction or low rank matrix
recovery now my signal or underlying
model is a matrix X naught that has rank
or its nyn let's say for simplicity we
assume a square and it's rank or and I'm
again obtaining M random Gaussian
measurements of that matrix meaning that
i'm taking inner product of the matrix
with random gaussian vectors so you
obtain mixtures of entries of the matrix
in each of your measurements the non
convex problem would be fine minimum
rank matrix subject to observations how
many measurements does it need the
answer is order n times r and n times r
is actually the degrees of freedom of a
rank or matrix because you can factorize
it as an end times R times R times and
matrix what about the convex relaxation
so what is the convex relaxation is the
sum of the singular values of the matrix
known as the trace nor no clear nor or
schatten one norm and solving this
problem we construct six not with very
high probability if the number of
observations are again order n times R
and this result goes back to initially
my work with been wrecked and Pablo
Perillo but it was improved to RN and
work of Candice and plant in 2009 and
many other people have looked at it as
well okay so what's interesting even
more striking in this problem is there
is no Jack order n times or measurements
convex problem works as well as the non
convex in the sample complex see sense
so this is pretty interesting that makes
makes us think well maybe this is a
typical phenomena maybe it's going to
happen everywhere so let's see a little
bit more about that now back to the
problem in which I had one model with
multiple structures simultaneously
structured models so now I'm going to
have an X naught I'm going to represent
it by a vector but imagine if it's a
matrix i'm going to vectorize it just
the point in a vector space I have X
naught and X naught has s different
structures could be sparse block sparse
lower-ranked binary and
the other known structures and each of
these structures come with its own norm
similar to what we just saw so those are
known so I have no number 1 2 norm
number is I want to impose all these
structures at the same time on the
object so what kind of a program should
i right well it seems like something
like this should work right that you
will be minimizing a function of all
these norms subject to the observations
and I won't consider a monster rock
class that is convex so any convex
combination of these zones so that means
i require H to be a convex and non
decreasing function in each argument
then the full objective function is a
convex function so this class of convex
programs covers for example your
objective could be a linear combination
of the norms with some regularization
parameter lambda oi it could be a point
wise maximum of the north again with
some parameters alpha i's and so on so
we're going to analyze such a program
and one quick observation is that when
you think about the question of how
North should mb for X not to be
recovered we could think of all these
problems in terms of a multi-objective
optimization problem so I have these
different norms let's say this is no
number one is no number two and I want
both of them to be small and you can
imagine there is a Pareto optimal curve
that as you change your parent orlando
or alpha you can traverse this curve but
the question you're interested in is
that i have a particular signal X naught
in mind and I want to see if I can
reconstruct that guy so you can easily
see that if it's not does not lie on the
pareto-optimal curve generated by your
problem there is no hope of recovering
excellent so our question is what is the
minimum m required for x naught to be on
the Perito curve now if X naught is on
the Perito curve then there are multiple
ways you can reconstruct it you can take
linear combination of the norms you can
take point for its maximum of the North
these would be the level curves of those
objective functions so there are
multiple ways and then one can tune
their alphas and Lando's and so on
however if m is not enough none of these
combinations with no Alfred Orlando will
work so we want to find that M so we are
going to show there is a gap in the
number of measurements
when you use this combination of
individual regular users compared to the
best possible and this gap shows up in
the compressed sensing question of how
many measurements I need to reconstruct
and it also shows up in the more
statistical question of how does mean
square error scale with noise so we're
going to then look at the special case
of sports on your rank matrices to make
it more concrete first we're going to
discuss this in a very general setting
why we have there any questions please
stop me at any time so there is a couple
of technical slides because I'm going to
make some assumptions that makes the
proofs possible but in some ways the
assumptions are not that essential it is
nice it makes the proofs nicer because
with these assumptions I will have a
notion of degrees of freedom of the
underlying object and some sort of
degrees of freedom corresponding to each
of these individual structures and norms
so I will make these assumptions but but
if you don't get the assumptions it's
fine if you don't want to bother with
them so first assumption is I'm going to
assume all the norms that are involved a
1 or nuclear norm a 1 2 norm etc are
decomposable norms become possible here
means that basically that their sub
differential at the point of interest
has a nice structure sub differential is
a set of all sub gradients so these
norms if you look at their balls deputy
they're not smooth and their corners and
at these corners you don't have a single
brilliant but you have a set of soft
gradients and we are assuming that sub
gradient has sub differential has a nice
structure so what what is the structure
enormous decomposable at a point X if
there exists a subspace T which plays
the role of the support of your ex and
the vector E that plays the role of sine
of X so why do we call them sign and
support is because if you specialize
this to the case of l1 norm its really
corresponds to the sign and support of a
vector sparsity on l1 or ok so there
exists T&E such that the sub
differential at point x decomposes into
the vector design vector and it has a
component orthogonal to it that has to
own or less than 1 ok sounds complicated
but what it is pictorially for l1 norm
is
so this is the unit ball of l1 norm in
two dimensions and this is the point X
that is sports it has one entry equal to
0 and the direct the vectors in play in
the plane that decrease the value of l1
norm as you're moving from X or vectors
that in this case point are inside the
norm ball and the sub gradients are the
negative of those vectors so here G is a
sub gradient vector the green vector now
does a 1 norm satisfy this assumption it
does because if you look at every sub
gradient it can be decomposed into e the
sign vector corresponding to this X
which in this case is the vector 10 and
a blue component that is orthogonal to
it this component that has infinity norm
less than 1 so it's between minus 1 and
1 infinity norm is a dual 12 1 or so a 1
on those satisfy your assumption we can
see it easily so does infinity no clear
known for matrices and so does a 12 not
ok so now I have a bunch of norms I have
s different norms and I'm going to be
looking at each of them having their own
support and sign vector so I have one
underlying signal X naught but each
piece of information I have about the
structure comes with a norm and calm but
norm comes with a tea and a e so now I
have a bunch of T's and islets index
them I have T sub I and II saw boy and
very important notion is the
intersection of all the T so void spaces
we call that teach app and that is the
subspace that actual X not lies in
because it externalizing on all the has
all the structures at the same time so
we're going to use that and we think we
need a couple of other notation so this
notation each app I is the projection of
the sign vector onto the intersection
subspace and we need also some notion of
angle which is basically it really what
it does is to capture the relative
geometry between these different norms
so are they close to each other are they
far away from each other they are
captured by this so this picture shows
roughly what we are talking about
structure number one comes with norm
number one and subspace t1 sign vector
e1 sign vector belong
to subspace T and same with the
structure number two and this is
excellent excellent lies in the
intersection of the two subspaces t1 and
t2 okay so that's all the setup we need
now here's a here's a simple first
result we can get if i solve this
optimization problem that i showed you
before minimizing a combination of the
individual norm subject to the
measurements and no matter what convex
on decreasing function h is it can be
the summation could be point-wise
maximum or anything we will the problem
will not work it will not give me x
naught if m is less than this value this
value has to do with the size of the
smallest sub gradient in the sub
differential not very intuitive right
yeah anybody has good intuition No so
let's bring this make one more
assumption try to massage this to see if
you get some intuition of what this
bound means it says if M is too small
this program will not work what what is
too small so i will add one more
assumption and i need that for technical
reasons and but it also holds in all the
cases of interest that you have looked
at the assumption is that these sign
individual sign vectors when projected
onto the intersection subspace have
positive inner product so they're not
pointing opposite to each other when i
make that assumption the previous bound
has now actually a nice form it says
that the optimization problem will fail
if m is less than some constant times
minimum of the dimension of the TI and
we'll discuss this constants later but
let's look at this term this is the
important term so if my measurements are
less than the smallest dimension of the
tis the program will not work so i need
at least the minimum dimension TI number
of measurements is that what he expected
well if i actually have an one object
that has all these structures at the
same time it lies in such a space it
lies in a space that whose dimension is
TCAP so so what we were expecting was i
I need only measurements that scale as
dimension of TCAP not individual teeth
and actually the individual T's can all
be very very high dimensional and
intersection can be very
dimensional so the gap here can be large
depending on what the problem is ok so
we owe observed an interesting yeah it's
not what we expected it can be
potentially a lot worse what if I have
some side constraints for example in my
initial example I showed the matrix was
also positive semi-definite is that
going to help me a lot the answer is
actually no it doesn't help with the
scaling so if I add additional corn
constraint on X not only these constants
change and I still am stuck with the
minimum of the dimension ok so a little
bit about the constants well actually
maybe I won't bother you with those I'll
just tell you this the continent numbers
that appeared in the previous slide
basically if you compute them for l1
norm its 1401 to norm its 14 Nucleonics
between a half and one so they're
constants so yeah basically we are the
bottleneck is that minimum of the
dimension of T is I'll skip over the
proof sketch but it's actually not that
complicated optimality conditions and a
little bit of properties of random
matrices random bosnian matrices ok so
this actually again captures the point I
was emphasizing which is let's this
specialized this result which was an
abstract result too sparse and low range
matrices ok so if X is a matrix X naught
is a matrix that is both low rank and
spars so let's say rank is our varsity
is K by K and I try to in this axis so
what's the number of required
measurements m so anything marked here
is a lower bound on the end the two
degrees of freedom of a matrix of rank
or with AK by K nonzero blog is
basically this number or x 2k minus or
essentially is order K times or what are
small numbers varsity and range so
that's three degrees of freedom we would
hope that we would need measurements of
along that order on that order if I were
able to write down the non convex
optimization problem i'm able to write
down but if i were able to solve this
optimization problem this one would
require order k log n plus K times or
measurements which are also still very
low so only a log in fact there were
some degrees of freedom and this is
analogous to what we saw for sparsity
and door
in the beginning however if I use a
convex relaxation that combines the two
norms individually like that the order
that's required in this case with the l1
to norm is n times R which is huge can
be very large n is the ambient dimension
there is another interesting one that
actually shows that if you weren't using
blocks varsity and you just used l1 norm
here you get something better than n
times are you actually gets k squared a
minimum of K square done in so that's
much better than this one but still much
higher than this one so it goes
somewhere here okay so we see a gap in
how well convex relaxation work when you
combine different structures and there
are some specific results the one I just
mentioned for a PSD matrix that is
ranked 1 and if I use a 1 norm and
nuclear norm the scaling goes like
minimum of K squared + n and I'll come
back to this number later we verified
this also by stimulation roughly
speaking we do see the ceiling as the
theory shows let me point out a second
problem so okay so first let me actually
ask you are there any questions about
this problem so far I talked about the
setting that was compressed sensing like
we had a number of random observations
of the underlying object we use that to
reconstruct the object and the question
the deep question was how many
measurements is needed sample complexity
and now I'm going to move to the next
problem which looks sounds different but
actually has the same mathematics so any
questions no okay so the second problem
is the simpler one the one I mentioned
in the beginning I have a signal X
naught that again has several structures
as structures come come with their nose
etc that is corrupted with noise so Z is
a noise vector that is iid Gaussian zero
mean variance Sigma squared let's say
and this problem here is simpler it's
just denoising so you won't get rid of
noise and a simple denoise ur is this
guy so i will i would like to minimize
the energy of the error energy of the
noise that's y minus x l 2 norm squared
and i would like to impose a
regularization term
on X naught to capture those structures
that we know so so if we do the same
thing as before we use a convex
combination again this can be that each
function so it can be general but
suppose we are using a linear
combination with parameters land oi so
if I use this I solve this optimization
problem then the minimizer is called X
hat and is an estimator so the question
if I want to judge how good this
estimator is is to look at the
difference between X hat minus X naught
l2 norm squared expected value so that's
this thing that's the mean squared error
of the estimator but people in practice
are interested in something a little bit
more which is well things change if I my
signals are scaled up and down if my
regularization parameters are changed so
how can we quantify so typical in this
area is to define the notion of mean
square error risk mfc risk and as
defined as follows the worst-case mean
square error overall scalings of my
signal X naught so gamma is a scalar
parameter and it's bigger than 0 and you
range it from very small to very large
you scale your signal up with respect to
the noise and then you ask how well does
this mean square work another way to
think of it is that that's the SNR
signal-to-noise ratio I want to see how
does the estimator work across different
regimes of signal to noise ratio so this
value etta which is the mean squared
error risk is the maximum overall gamma
of the mean squared error and it's a
function of these parameters lando want
to land OS I can tune the nando's and
get a better risk you can certainly do
that so here we have written as a
function of the Lando's so this notion
of risk and the problem of de-noising
and using different norms for denoising
has been studied a lot of papers in fact
for l1 norm it's a there is classical I
didn't include that result but for more
recently it has been looked at for
general atomic norms it has been looked
at in the context of sports BCA again by
a minion vein roids and more recently
the phase transition phenomenon in this
setting has been looked at by
home on tour and others so but we are
looking at the setting in which we have
simultaneous structures they were all
looking at a single structure so what do
we get so here's a result basically if
we make a similar assumption to what we
had before which was this positive inner
product between the sign vectors pairs
of signed actors we get a lower bound on
how well this estimator can do this
lower bound basically says you cannot do
better than this right and the lower
bound in ends up being a constant and I
can drop this one it doesn't matter and
this thing is a constant s is the number
of structures again small integer so
ends up being a constant times again the
minimum of the dimensions of the support
spaces ti so same quantity showed up
again and that means I have the same
bottleneck no matter how I tune these
Lando's that estimator is never going to
perform better than this quantity so it
depends on what the minimum dimension of
two eyes are so let's again specialized
this to the case of sports and or rank
matrices specifically let's look at rank
one matrix ease so X now is a rank one
matrix this outer product of little X
and little why it doesn't need to be
square so this can be different and x
and y our case force vectors their unit
norm and i would like to reconstruct
this matrix given noisy measurements why
so noise here is a matrix Z whose
entries again argh I ID Gaussian zero
mean and so on so I'm going to solve
this optimization problem and I'm by the
way as in the previous slide I forgot to
mention those of you an optimization
immediately recognize what this is it's
the proximal operator of this function
at point x at Point y so if you have
seen it with that term or or I guess
those of you in statistics would think
this is called what soft thresholding
operator with respect to that one when
you plug in specific norms then usually
it has a simple answer so for example if
you just plug in an l1 norm here its
actual soft entry why stop special link
and if it's no clear norm its
software holding on singular values etc
etc so there are familiar results there
so the estimator is actually not
surprising but the behavior when we are
adding different norms with each other
is is interesting that's what you are
looking at ok so back to the example the
low ranking sports example I solve this
problem so I'm putting a penalty on the
l1 norm of the matrix another penalty on
the nuclear norm of the matrix and our
result shows specialized to this case
shows that the best possible etter the
best possible MSC risk is bounded above
and below by these quantities the
quantity below will depend on X on Y but
I can actually get an estimate of its
order by plugging in some X and voice
this equality is tight when x and y have
a 1 norm proportional to square root k
which can happen for example if the x
and y's have entries that are plus minus
1 over square root k so with sine
vectors plus minus 1 vectors you can
achieve the equality on the order and
when you plug in that so the l1 norm
would then be square root k and this
would be square root k so this would be
k then the whole scaling is going to be
minimum of k squared + n so a lower
bound on the best possible mean square
or your estimator can achieve skills as
minimum of k squared + n but k is the
sparsity of the factors and n is the
ambience sighs and there's a lower bound
the lower bound is actually easier to
derive actually there are several other
works also deriving this law sorry the
upper bound but interesting thing is
look at this the upper bound also has K
squared log N and this goes all the way
to K squared so it's very tight I mean
the upper and lower bounds are tight
within a log factor so I'm emphasizing
here the lower bound i'm using the upper
bound to say to show that it's actually
tight ok so here's the picture we get
for the denoise ink problem if I again
look at and now this axis corresponds to
the mean squared error that MSC risk
theater let me start from the top if I
use this problem for what we had i'm
going to i'm actually using the fact
that the matrix X is block sparse so i'm
using the l1 to norm a 1
to norm is nothing but the sum of the
two norms of the columns of a matrix if
I use this as in order to induce block
sparsity and I use nuclear norm in order
to induce low rankness the performance
here is very bad this order n
interestingly if i use l1 instead of l12
and nuclear norm it's better it's order
a minimum of k squared + n is less than
n but still is away from the true
minimum degrees of freedom or what you
would hope to get or the best possible
so there's a gap here but actually even
more interesting i should have marked is
the gap here the gap between this k
squared n k now can I ever do better
than K squared yeah it turns out there
is a very simple algorithm almost
trivial that you can do and actually
performs with the order K the minimum
mean square error will be scale as order
K and this I want presented by is
actually a simple two-step thresholding
probably it exists in the literature
what it does is that you threshold the
entries basically do a hard thresholding
with respect to the sparsity and then do
a soft trash holding with respect to the
singular values on on the for Denorfia
norm and then it's right on that so its
a mix of convex on non convex iteration
and seems like it should be should not
work what it actually works and one can
actually prove it works with this order
of measurement so it brings up this
interesting question of what's what's
going on with this convex problem why is
there such a gap so we don't know that
answer but let me show you some
numerical experiments and then there's
it i will discuss what's possible
interesting things might be going on
there ok so these numerical experiments
show a case of this de-noising problem
where the ambient dimension is 30 so
there is a signal of size 30 and outer
product so you get a matrix 30 by 30
fairly small but still you still see the
behavior of the scaling these are the
sparsity levels k goes from three to 24
and this is the empirical mean square
error so there is a hundred simulations
for each combination and then it's
averaged and this is the average MSC as
the signal-to-noise ratio or gamma
changes the empirical MSE also changes
when gamma is very small sparsity does
not play a big role MSE is very small
across a big range of sparsity but as
gamma grows for example gamma close to a
hundred then as kate grows the mean
square error also grows so it grows with
gamma in fact that maximum or worst case
means square risk happens when gamma
approaches infinity and okay and this
actually this is a bound that
approximates a theoretical bound that I
didn't describe here but you can do that
and so this was not part of our
simulation but you can compare to that
mount the true value of the mean square
error risk is related to its actually
related to distance of the noise vector
to the cone of the sub differential and
you can approximate that as well so so
that blue curve shows that so the point
is the behavior of the program convex
program and here we have fixed the two
Lando's to be these two values we just
picked on by trial and error it is as
expected and it's growing with K the MSE
error is growing with K and here is the
other interesting one in which we are
contrasting the convex program whose
behavior we studied and this very simple
two-step fresh holding non convex thing
the very simple non-core mixing is
actually performing better in all
regimes pretty much compared to the
convex relaxation these are all the
convex relaxations with different tuning
on the parameters so of course if you
tune it bad these performs badly but
this is the best tuned one the dark blue
so these are the optimal Lando's and
that gives you this performance is still
worse than the non convex performance so
and actually the gap is larger in the
smaller case so that's the interesting
phenomena that there is a gap now the
convex relaxation is not capturing
through behavior based on degrees of
freedom you would expect so okay so to
summarize we look like two different
problems both of them involve
simultaneously structured models
we looked at compressed sensing setup in
which you have measurements of that
object that you used to reconstruct the
object and we looked at a simpler
statistical denoising problem where you
have the the signal corrupted by noise
and you want to get rid of the noise so
the result is the following that the
most typical thing to do and actually in
practice people do this a lot is to just
combine all your regular I zors and form
one big optimization problem with them
and if you're concerned about sample
complexity at least gaussian sample
complexity that that approach displays a
potentially large gap with the best
possible which wasn't studied before so
it's interesting to observe that and
both for sample complexity and for
denying risk in the Indy statistical
setting that there is a fundamental
limitation and a gap and contrast this
for the case of l1 norm as a relaxation
for sparsity no gap there only a large
factory gap in sample complexity or rank
versus no clear norm again no gap there
it was both order n times or so so
that's that I think brings up some very
interesting questions and yeah hopefully
if anybody's interested we can discuss
it more but one suggestion of how can
one address that is that can we
construct a better convex relaxation for
example and one suggestion to do that is
that well in theory yes that's possible
and the nice work of van Cott
chandrasekaran been rigged public radio
and alan will ski shows that you can
always construct something called atomic
norms at least in theory if you have
something called atoms appropriately
corresponding to your structures and you
can take their convex hall then you can
have a norm that is guaranteed to behave
the right way the problem is in a lot of
cases especially in the lower ranking
sports case I showed constructing that
norm itself is np-hard you can't take
the appropriate convex hull so in theory
there exists a great norm but may not be
computationally feasible then some
special cases there has been work on
special cases for example people use a
combination of l1 norm and on to non
penalties and it has a name in
statistics called the elastic net and
recently that was studied in the work of
cerebro who actually showed l1 plus
too isn't the best and you can construct
a better penalty but the improvement was
only a constant factor it was not a big
improvement over this then there has
been some other individual work
case-by-case so I appears that one has
to then address these cases individually
so that's that's really open another
interesting thing that I didn't discuss
is that in fact my one of my motivating
examples was the optical phase retrieval
problem in that problem the measurements
are actually not random Gaussian like I
assumed afterwards what they are are
they there outer product of these
vectors you can assume each vector is
random but they're these they have this
outer product for so one has to do the
probabilistic analysis property properly
for this model and that was done in the
paper by Leon and grown in ski showing
similar lower bounds in fact very
similar to the Gaussian case so actually
that's an example of a case you go away
from the Gaussian assumption you need to
do more work but once you do it you
actually get similar flavored result at
least for this specific type of
measurements they got similar bounds um
one thing I'm very interested in is
further connections to sparse PC a
problem I don't fully yet understand it
but it seems interesting that we have
this regime of minimum of K squared n n
that convex relaxation is talking and
based on some recent work of Philip
recolor and Quentin dirty and others
there could be a fundamental limitation
there so it could be it could be that if
we connect these two problems we will
see that there is no pain no meal time
algorithm that's going to do better than
this so not just are convex relaxation
but nothing polynomial time so it's open
what's interesting potential connection
there is also other recent improved
convex relaxations for example
specifically for the problem of sports
and no rank matrices you can revisit the
problem instead of saying i'm adding
your one Norman nuclear known just
construct another relaxation and there
has been work by richard bach and there
and they have they have improved the
relaxation but appears that this k
squared gap is still not bridged ok so
that's the summary and deserve some
reference
if you're interested so thank you yes
yes so if I understood correctly the
compressed sensing result was an exact
recovery result and the question is what
if you have noise in those measurements
so basically that question means can I
put together the two pieces of the talk
probably yes so the first part of the
talk we didn't have noise and we had
exact measurements and we talked about
the exact recovery the second part is
only noise but we didn't have compressed
measurements so the next step would be
to put them together so we have G X
minus y l 2 norm less than epsilon and
then look at the answer of that
optimization problem and try to say
something about the MSC row there so we
haven't written it down but conceivably
we should be able to get I think so yeah
haven't written down but based on these
two individual voices and noisy cases we
studied I think so
um no we don't have convergence
guarantees but if it converges converges
to the right thing basically yeah I have
to check it again make it does converse
what we just don't know yeah so I fixed
them perfectly it worked really well but
yeah let me look at it more carefully to
see exactly what we know about this
convergence we know you don't have an
exact because it's a non-convex
procedure we basically did it really as
a benchmark to see how far the convex
relaxation is to best possible so this
was a proxy up as possible but here's
one method which was constructed is yeah
exactly
you